The Washington Post reports on the
tunnel collapse at the hand for nuclear
waste site in Washington state workers
at the nation's most contaminated
nuclear facility are closely monitoring
the air quality the tunnel that
collapsed stores railroad cars filled
with decades-old radioactive waste
plutonium for nuclear weapons was made
at the massive site in eastern
Washington for more than four decades
John Blackstone is outside the site
which is nearly half the size of Rhode
Island John good morning good morning
well the motto on the sign here at
Hanford where safety comes first will be
put to the test today
as crews attempt to determine what
caused the ground above this tunnel to
collapse now there's been no radioactive
release detected but experts say that
this shows the deteriorating conditions
at this troubled nuclear facility
respond Urich not all for a possible
collapse of the tunnel nearly five
thousand workers took cover Tuesday
morning after a 20 by 20 foot area of
soil collapsed over a tunnel used to
store contaminated radioactive materials
at Hanford James Lopez's girlfriend
works at the site it's pretty scary they
put her in a room and they cut off all
the ventilation so that the outside air
couldn't get in the breach happened near
the center of the five hundred square
mile your complex old rail cars used to
transport plutonium and uranium are now
stored in wood and concrete tunnels
covered by about eight feet of soil dirt
collapse into the tunnel nobody's
involved there's no people involved
Hanford emergency operations official
Destry Henderson updated the public on
Facebook no signs of a radiological
release additionally no employees have
been injured Hanford is home to 56
million gallons of radioactive waste all
of the waste from the Manhattan Project
which tested and built the atomic bomb
during World War two is buried there the
facility has been closed for nearly 30
years
but 9,000 people now work at the site on
a massive cleanup effort some of this
nuclear waste is so hot that if you were
to walk by it you would get conceivably
a lethal dose of radiation CBS News
science contributor Michio Kaku
who says it could take another 40 years
and 110 billion dollars before the site
may be considered safe the Hanford
reservation is a series of disasters
waiting to happen a major earthquake a
major fire at the site with all these
toxic much of them flammable liquids
could cause a disaster beyond our
imagination fixing the damaged tunnel
could be challenging Energy Department
officials say they're looking for a way
to create a barrier between the
contaminated material and the outside
air but in doing that work they'll have
to work carefully to make sure they
don't make this hole any larger all
right thank you John